père ou détestez-le à vue il est
plus intelligent que lui et son noir j'ai rencontré
l'homme je veux passer ma vie n'est
-ce pas es-tu fou n'est-ce pas et c'est une
fille autodidacte mon grand-père était
roi
je suis son héritier j'ai une responsabilité  pour
rentrer chez moi auprès de mon peuple, je ne
réaliserai jamais rien qui vaille si je donne mon
cœur ouais
si vous choisissez d'épouser le chef d'une
nation africaine, vous serez responsable
de la chute de l'empire britannique
en Afrique n'avez-vous pas honte pendant deux
décennies  de vous préparer à être notre roi,
c'est ainsi que vous faites face combien de temps
avant que la poussière du village ne pénètre dans ses yeux, on
me dit que vous ne souhaitez plus que
j'honore mon devoir de roi à cause de
la couleur de la femme que j'ai  choisi
tu appartiendras aux blancs mais ils
te veulent mais j'aime ma femme maintenant tu
verras comment un empire se défend mr.
Conor, nous avons conclu que vous devriez
être exilé J'appartiens à mon peuple
Premier ministre que le monde entier
regarde
- plus fort qu'aucun de nous ne le soupçonnait, il est
temps pour nous de créer une nouvelle nation
pour être les maîtres de notre propre coffre-fort, il est
temps que
vous